hello sweet internet i'm gav i'm dan
that's dj dan we're the slow-mo guys a
while ago we did a video where we spun a
cd so fast it shook itself to pieces it
sort of warbled and then flung out
warbled yeah right okay well this time
we've got some records we're kicking at
old school
yeah i feel bad breaking these to be
honest yeah it's almost like ripping a
book it's just not to be done is it i
know you mean but we i did get them from
goodwill yeah so i feel like people are
done with them they've experienced it
now we're going to put them to a second
use in a second life so immortalized
forever on the internet so this is the
loading procedure
if you didn't see the previous video
then i'll explain something this is
actually the motor from inside of a i
think it's a dyson
so it can spin at incredibly high speeds
i think that's
probably all right
god imagine putting a needle on this
what it would sound like it would be
it's already kind of wonky
this record isn't perfectly straight you
know when you see them being played on a
gramophone they kind of go like yeah
like that
i don't know if this is going to survive
long so because we're just using the
motor from a dyson
it's an incredibly fast hoover motor
that's how it works it spins really fast
but if you just turn it on straight away
it would be spinning at maximum speed
and that's just kind of not what we want
we want to get the gradual build up and
then eventually the braking of the
record so for that we're going to use
this variac which means that you put the
you put a voltage through it and you can
vary the output increasing it gradually
until we hit that exact breaking point
we need i'm excited yeah me too slightly
scared too yeah it makes a hell of a
noise it's really intimidating shooting
on the v2640 we're gonna start at 12 and
a half thousand frames a second
i think if this works we'll paint one
all right one different quadrant so you
can see it spin better sounds good to me
this damn vice is going everywhere this
thing is so powerful it's like shaking
the vice everywhere it's like tightening
it down
[Music]
god that goes
that goes whoa look at this
oh it's like colored it's turned it into
oh
geez that's crazy how did it go
oh it just got eviscerated i think oh
look there's a big chunk of it there
that's a big chunk
okay yeah i was all the way over there
and some tiny little like tiny little
fragments were like bounced off of this
went little bits of musical dust yeah
dust yeah i think that was you know what
i think that took more than the cd
really i think so look what it's done to
the wood here oh it's like embedded
itself in the wood
fully almost cracked the wood open
this is lethal i'm actually glad we put
these up
yeah you know i was getting worried that
we were going to send it across the
fences well if there's pieces like this
then it's possible at this speed it's
almost like you could play the music at
it yeah this is the music speed yeah
this is what she was actually this is
slowed down to be oh
yes now it's warping
uh you can see on the reflection that
it's going a bit
it must just happen at a certain speed
where it's like and now i'm walking it's
weird because it
stabilizes initially
there's like a chunk of it still on
there god okay let's do that frame by
frame okay so it's split from the middle
see that crack yeah i see that
worked its way through
turned into like a tree either side
that's so weird it looks like lightning
going through it
it pretty much does and that means that
one like each of those halves is now
like really vulnerable to cracking and
then
oh and the other look on the left
they're just going
they just turn to glass like they just
turn to dust it's kind of good that
we've got the blocks there because it
show it like shatters it after it's gone
yeah
because there were some big chunks
coming out of that let's i think we
should move the uh blocks on the right
side just slightly further away
oh it's just the edge i think just for
safety we should build up one higher
you think so
yeah
like this is coming off as some
ridiculous clip
lots of riches some clip because we've
got enough light i'm just going to
change the shutter angle to 90 degrees
each exposure is now
20 microseconds approximately
which should well get rid of half the
motion blur oh i also need a shield
i'll just hide behind that wood thing
or the tree
too far away too far away yeah the wires
don't reach
yep
[Applause]
whoa
i was like there's not much more to give
on this really yeah i was nearly full
whack there
i was
there's surely no way it's at its full
speed with that on it like the the motor
is only going to spin a small fan but
because maybe because the record is
heavier it's slowing it down more so
it's not being able to get the same rpm
yeah this one's cracked slightly
different it's not in such a straight
line it's gone like sideways you can see
the marks that it's left on the on the
brick really yeah you wanna watch this
okay you ready
that one was different because it crept
from the outside
see the crack at the bottom now yeah
three four five six seven eight nine
frames it was gone that broke really
similarly to the cd yeah that was
because it broke from the outside that
was exactly how the cd went and then it
just misted itself it's like glitter
look at the sparkle
so let's move everything six feet back
oh god there's so much effort to move
those kind of blocks it's ridiculous so
we thought we'd make it easier to to be
able to do maths on this so we painted
quadrants well you painted
i say i painted quadrants it's not
really it's a blue is questionable it's
got sort of a slightly bigger piece of
the pie
you just complain about everything don't
you
i can't do anything right
you didn't say do like an amazing job of
it i just it was just like a basic thing
sorry i didn't measure it out to the
millimeter
god
should i put the should i preface
everything now oh by the way do an
amazing job on it yeah
otherwise i'll just do a shoddy job
obviously i like it i think it's funny
okay
it's locked in there so let's play a
guessing game
yeah
so there's always a piece that goes
straight up and doesn't shatter
what color do you think it will be
i reckon blue oh yellow yellow for sure
all right i wonder what color that'll
look like when it's spinning
i mean if it was red green and blue it
would appear white but because the
yellow appear yellow yeah maybe
let me just document your shield all
right well first of all i've got to be
in comfort so i've got a nice uh
recliner behind here yeah so that i can
do it in comfort and second of all
that's your period i'm hidden behind
here with the variac i'll use my head to
shield myself
turn it on and then just like
[Music]
golly gosh me
so i ended up breaking 115 there but
it's only got this much more to give
so it's really at the limits of hungry
yeah it really is angry lad yeah there's
another crack from the outside that one
shall see
[Music]
oh wow
it looks cool with the colors isn't it
it's like a really convoluted way of
painting yeah blue went up
damn it without even seeing the slo-mo
you can tell which colors went where
because if you look green is all at the
bottom there you follow it around and
it's all the red
then it slowly turns to blue well that's
that's why the sky is blue yeah
got me the last of that
and then there's more blue and then it
goes yellow i think it broke more or
less perfectly in quarters blue yellow
green red we're now looking at this edge
to see how much it warps
[Music]
i thought the whole wood top went
oh geez
oh
look at that
look at the damage it's done here
oh
god that's insane it's insane it looks
like scarring look you can see the
individual pieces that have hit it and
the way the fact they've gone more
wobbly as it goes along and then come
back again look it's gone like you can
see a graph where it's gone wobbly and
then not so wobbly i bet if it carried
on it'd be like this
like a wave it's a way to record onto a
physical medium yeah it's like an
instant graph it goes like this like
that and then it comes back around again
and it goes like a wave all the way
around
i bet that's exactly what you'll see on
the slimmer that is a severe amount of
water wow
i'm surprised this even managed to stay
in focus it's moving around so much just
pulling
isn't it it really is
oh it's fish in the middle oh did it
yeah
oh wow i was hoping it would split
exactly on the on the front focus line
well that would be amazing
i wonder what the
like how much centimeters wise it was
actually varying in wobblemen
i guess we'll just do one more
tada what a beaut thank you this one is
being shot square
so we can stabilize it in post and spin
the shot
in theory i've also got the wood in the
shot so if we see any of that scarring
we'll go to see how i did it oh yeah
powering up engines starting jet
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good lord
one came directly at this thing did it i
heard it audibly like go
there must have been a rebound there's
no way it would have come straight out
yet no exactly it must have like
rebounded off the off the stone
oh from the outside again
from the blue
[Music]
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
so let's see which pick came at you
so it came off the corner
that must have been what hit you you
think so it must it was kind of the same
sort of angle look at how fast that's
spinning towards her i definitely i
almost felt it though
so it must have been a chunky piece did
you say my name
huh
a chunky piece yes my nickname
look at the 3d nature of some of this
stuff
it's just absolutely compressed get some
side on it looks like someone's taken
like mascara and wiped it on a brick
wall look it looks like someone's just
going like
yeah yeah that's some more
you know what's good about that video
what's that
we've shattered all the records
is that good
what do you mean like you're doing a
record-breaking pun
well yeah yeah you know what with your
puns you're like one of these
like
broken record
there you go
that was insane we never had this cage
around it last time when it was the cd
because it was so light it just lost all
its velocity like the drag from all the
air just slowed it all down
this stuff
this could have gone
miles well the very fact that this still
exists after hitting the cage yeah she
tells you like this is super thick as
well right in the middle it's the
records are thicker than they are on the
outside so the outside bits hit this and
turn to dust and these would go flying
but luckily
most of the energy is taken out by
hitting them yeah these parts are bigger
a because they were in the center and
they were released at a slower velocity
and also the label sort of holds it
together yeah
that was crazy i'm glad it's over
because that was kind of scary what i
might do i might take a picture of these
and post it on twitter and i'll say
you'll never guess how we painted these
bricks no one will get i don't think
anyone's going to know no one
but i don't think a record has ever been
used in that way before
no no well that was a that was a
record-breaking record breaking yeah
i think it was i think it was a it was a
record-breaking squad
god
well that was cool
hopefully you enjoyed that video feel
free to subscribe to our very channel
right here we've got a second one as
well behind the scenes i play pranks on
down a lot don't i yeah you do yeah i do
and uh
all the social medias and stuff
thank you very much for watching
do you know um in the future yeah when
like you know how we have like
archaeologists that would go to places
like rome and greece and yeah and piece
together all the pottery and be like
this was used to store grain do you
think in the future they'll find these
and be like
well
and they'll glue one of these all
together it appears to have been
shattered apart by itself yeah
yeah this is where you grow graves
that's what they sound like or the guy
from time team he was like
right this this the guy that wasn't
talking
the one with the long hair it was
clearly faking a west country
yeah as soon as he got on camera he was
just like oh you talk like this now
i just talked like this normally and
then uh cut thank you thank you yeah
yeah they get in the trailer yeah